so we're talking about new beginning
with old friends but we should also be
clear
from the first of january on and this is
in three weeks
the uk will be a third country to the
european union
well that was the european commission
president ursula vandalian giving the uk
a post-brexit reality
check on sunday another self-imposed
deadline
blew by this one to secure a tr
trade deal before britain leaves the eu
single market on january first
funder lion and uk prime minister boyce
johnson they've agreed to extend the
talks pledging to go
an extra mile but the path forward it is
narrow
and with just two weeks to negotiate
time
is running out this is what the eu's
chief negotiator michelle barnier
tweeted today as talks continue in
brussels the eu commission is preparing
for
quote all eventualities
and there are lots of them let's go to
dw's charlotte chelsea pill now she is
on the story for us tonight in london
good evening to you
charlotte after what happened uh in
brussels
is the uk government is it now preparing
for
a no deal or do they still think that a
a trade deal
is possible
well brent up until yesterday when we
heard that that deadline was missed and
the negotiations are set to continue the
talk
coming from both sides was that no deal
was looking like the very
likely outcome of these negotiations
then though
ursula fondline who we heard just there
from the eu commission
put out a statement saying talks would
continue she said that they had been
constructive and that they had been a
useful buoying hopes for many who are
hoping for
a deal to be the outcome of these
negotiations but this has happened
so many times brent then boris johnson
the prime minister here
came out with his own statement pouring
a little bit of cold water on that he
said
just yesterday in his own words well if
ursula uh
fonder line is optimistic then that's
great but they are still
big gaps on several key issues and brent
they're the key issues that have been
plaguing these talks for so
many weeks now the issue of eu fishing
access to uk
waters the so-called level playing field
that's the issue of competition between
eu and uk
companies and enforcement governance as
well being the third key
issue which is proving uh so problematic
here and look brent the fact is as
you've said it is
less than uh three weeks now until the
transition
period uh ends so the question is
now not just can a deal be done but can
it be done in time and
the only people who really are going to
know that are those who are sat around
the negotiating table because while
we here as journalists might be fed bits
of information here
and there it's unclear exactly how much
of that is is just
uh blustered to trade talking tough
as these negotiations really do go down
to a red line or whether or not whether
there are indeed some
some real genuine issues that might uh
stifle any hopes of a deal
yeah that is true i want you to take a
listen to some reactions in the uk from
people
about the state of these negotiations
to extend it is wasting time really i
don't think they're going to come to any
kind of agreement
i'm not sure i'm that optimistic but i'm
hoping we get a deal i'll be very
disappointed if we don't
very very disappointed they can't be
bullying us around and forcing us into
something that is
makes us a client state of the eu well
too late isn't it
four years we're down to the last hours
um i can't believe they've had four
years to sort this out but still you
know
he's still in his position it's the
shambles really you know charlotte you
talk to lots of people
you get this mixture of anger
disappointment resignation you and i
we've talked about brexit
countless times what's your take
yeah brian i mean those comments that we
just heard are comments that i've
heard over and over again here in the uk
there is a real sense of fatigue now as
these talks drag
drag on and it doesn't help of course
that we keep seeing these deadlines
like the one that passed on yesterday
which was self-imposed
coming and going still without a deal
here and you have to remember that the
uk like the rest of the world is still
struggling with
kobe we've heard just today that more
restrictions here in london are coming
into place coming into place
a lot of people really do have a wait
and see approach now they'll
start to pay attention again when they
know whether or not there is or isn't
going to be a deal but
for so many people who have businesses
who have dealings with the european
union they don't have the luxury
of wait and see and there is some real
anger among business groups farming
unions
who say that there are just days now
until the transition period ends and
they still don't know
exactly what they're preparing for now
the government line for weeks has been
well there are going to be changes
either way but if you talk to farmers
uh in the agriculture industry the
automobile the car
industry they're saying well you know
what if a deal does
no deal does materialize that is going
to be incredibly disruptive so
real concerns here particularly when the
uk is facing uh so much damage
in the economy from uh the coronavirus
yeah
you know charlotte some would say that
this is exactly what boris johnson
always wanted running down the clock
with the eu
against the wall i mean what are the
possible calculations at this point
well from a lot that i've been reading
from the eu
side that's exactly what they would love
to know exactly what
boris johnson hopes to achieve
once privately publicly though his line
for a long time has been that the uk
would prefer to have a deal but not at
any cost
he also repeated just yesterday that the
uk would do uh
very very well his words uh with
uh or without a deal so what he
thinks privately is still a little bit
unknown there are certainly many within
his party who would
sleep easy uh the idea of a
of a no deal materializing what happens
though we will just
have just days to find that out the
transition period ending december 31st
that is right time is ticking away dw
charlotte chelsea pill on the story for
us tonight in london as always
charlotte thank you